just wanted to describe to viewers what
we can see this is thornton heath in
South London you can see that this is
one of the parks that is being searched
by police at the moment after that young
man was last seen by his parents at
about one o'clock this morning he was
subsequently seen on CCTV at about seven
o'clock this morning and then a viewer
watching sky news this afternoon
contacted police she thought she had
seen him boarding a bus heading towards
Brixton that was about eight o'clock
this morning but Richard nothing since
then no nothing since then but you know
he to the family will seem like a very
long time but this is a very very
fast-moving investigation I set off from
Scotland Yard at about two o'clock
before I managed to make it down to here
in Croydon the story had already moved
on it became clear that he was not seen
eight o'clock so everything's moving
very quickly obviously police and had to
move all their resources around but I
would imagine that for the families you
know to see images like this on the
television of police searching a
woodland you know when it's your own
child involved must be absolutely awful
but it's really worth me emphasizing
that we have been encouraged to be here
by the family by the police because it's
absolutely vital that you
the public keep their eyes open and help
the police in searching for this boy
because we so desperately needs
medication if he doesn't get his three
doses today there's every chance you
could fall into a coma if he hasn't
already so we are here to really try and
help get that message out but as I say
no sighting since eight o'clock this
morning